on the topic of food so with it being
christmas right now and everyone's just
had
their christmas meals and everything
like that what uh
what are your what are your preferences
in your christmas meals
because i i'll be honest like so so last
year we all celebrated christmas
together
and we had a hot pot and yeah about the
traditional
it was it was a great [ __ ] hot pot
but i ain't gonna lie
it just it just just felt like something
was missing yeah it's not that's not the
[ __ ] turkey and whatever chicken
okay i will say this i think turvey's
turkey's overrated as [ __ ] man i don't i
don't understand the hype behind turkey
turkey i i think turkey is just like an
inferior chicken
it is it is right like imagine chicken
but just drier with less taste that's
just turkey like i don't understand
why all the holidays you know what it is
it's someone who just got a turkey and
just went into photoshop and did this
[Music]
it's like everything is thinner it's
just bigger i think if you have like a
real nice turkey like that's been like
seasoned well you it's i think it could
be no because like
the problem with turkey is that if even
if it's seasoned well right
you get you get the outer part that's
nice and seasoned but then you get to
the inner [ __ ] triad
that's why you got to cook it are you
going to cut it in a way where you get
like the skin and the meat in the same
bite but you can do that with chicken
yeah but with less price yeah yeah but i
feel like you can make a turkey like
skin taste better than chicken
i don't know it depends where lean
agrees and you know melee yeah but
melanie's american
okay so if you don't like turkey then do
you like any other meats because
sometimes my family used to do like duck
or ham oh my my dad would make like a
roast ham yeah like
rice pork right i think genuinely like
pork is the best
for like christmas i know it's turkey's
the traditional and chicken's like the
back up
but i think we never did turkey at home
really i think a good [ __ ] ham is
just like
you can't beat that [ __ ] yeah wait
define what you mean by ham do you mean
like roast
pork or like we did like uh we did like
a lego hand
you could do either like because i don't
really like ham
like like roast ham because i don't like
anything this is [ __ ] men like
anything
i know like what's wrong with that like
kind of like a gammon steak
kind of like that yeah it could be
because i i'm like no
i'm i'm like not a fan of gammon that's
just like the inferior part
it's amazing it's literally it is
literally the opposite it is literally
the more expensive bacon
that's literally what gammon is i've
never heard what is a gammon gammon's
like a
way more like a meteor uh cut of the the
pig
oh that's normally more expensive than
because bacon is the cheapest part of
the pizza right right
right and it's [ __ ] and gammon's like
the actual bacon is the best part of the
pig
thank you very like you think that much
stuff that's how are you gonna argue
that bacon is not the best part of the
pit it's the most overrated part of the
pig
bacon bacon used to be like the [ __ ] i
literally know
i literally know vegetarians who have
been converted to meat eaters because of
bacon
i think it's just it's the meme right
everyone says bacon is like the best
food right it's because americans put
bacon with everything
it's because the smell of bacon there
there is nothing that can like match
this
bacon is like it's it's not that great
like it just kind of tastes
okay just give me like a nice piece of
pork or especially the american bacon
[ __ ] what are you talking about
american bacon is american bacon is the
best bacon
[ __ ] awful it's the best bacon like
stop clapping man
british back bacon is like the worst
bacon it's that it's the best way to
have bacon
like no i just don't have bacon because
right normal bacon is like 50 to 70
like the american one like fat it's more
fat than yeah that i'm not saying it's
healthy
but i'm saying it tastes [ __ ] bad it
doesn't taste good like fat inherently
just tastes like [ __ ]
the meat is the best part no no no no no
there's no reason why it's more
expensive one thing the one thing i
don't like about bacon is that it is
way too overpowering especially when you
put it with other things
like if you have like a if you have like
say like you put bacon on a burger for
instance
a lot of people love that [ __ ] right
yeah but for me when bacon is on a
burger all i taste is the [ __ ] bacon
like i'd rather just i rather just
replace everything with bacon it'll
taste the same it's like it's like the
nice caramel
that you need
i like making my burger because i don't
need any ketchup or mayo or [ __ ]
whatever my burger
you want no sauce whatsoever on your
burger no you're [ __ ] clowns man
actually like that's probably why he
likes turkeys because it's like the
driest [ __ ] birdies
it is like water this water that yeah
i want my bacon to be all fat just give
me the [ __ ] give me the driest [ __ ]
burger
and non-tap water literally streaky
bacon
is like beyonce's the better bacon what
the [ __ ] is street
streaky bacon is the american bacon so
like i didn't know how
like because whenever americans british
bacon is similar to
canadian that's the way they say what's
it to america british bacon is just like
half
so so british bacon is more like it's
like eighty to ninety percent bacon
right
and it's like ten percent fat on the
edge yeah it's like a thicker right
yeah yeah yeah and like as a kid i i
would hate british bacon because i would
just like
i would just like eat the bacon pass
first and then like
save all the fatty part for later
because that was the best tasting
fat on its own you're actually
disgusting because it wasn't even safe
it wasn't the fat part it was the fat
with like the little [ __ ] piece of meat
in there and then i realized that
american bacon is just all that see
american bacon is just like the best
part of the bacon
because actually like we actually had a
podcast where you were arguing about
food and then you sit here and tell me
you just want to eat fat
like you just want fat and i should i
was just going to give a [ __ ] about your
food
and this man doesn't eat the crust on a
pizza right it's like it's like the
fatty part of a bacon is literally the
equivalent of how you've labeled a crust
on a pizza no it's the [ __ ] opposite
because the crust in the pizza tastes
like nothing
and the the most tastiest part of the
bacon is the fatty part
that's why americans have figured out
the the best tasting part of the bacon
because they've just taken the streaky
bacon
which is the the most tastiest part all
if it's just the bacon part like i've
talked about this the bacon part
is just to me like pork is just vanilla
vanilla beef we've talked about this and
like the only part
that's better is the fatty part of the
pores like pork belly
pork belly tastes [ __ ] great and
that's mostly fat
you gotta eat okay okay i admit pork
belly's [ __ ] bomb yeah that's because
it's
that's cooked differently yeah yeah and
it's also not a very like cheap part
yeah bacon is inherently different
that's an expensive part of the pork
it's no it's because of the fat it's
because it's because of the fatty
content
that's what gives it the flavor yeah but
if you just eat the pork but
pork by itself i think it's a shelly
yeah so you get chunks where you get a
bit like half meat yeah and then half
fat right
but that's like an actual like richness
to it because it's chunky it's like an
actual like black
i just don't [ __ ] with the taste of
bacon and normally pork belly is not
like
on its own it's normally something it's
like in a broth or something where it's
like bacon it's like you can have it
with other things but again it just
overpowers
everything no one makes a [ __ ] broth
out of bacon like that's just disgusting
because it's [ __ ]
someone in america is like um excuse me
someone try that out please
when we spoke about the food episode and
we got really heated like day or two
after joe was like you know what i can't
i think you're right about pork yeah no
i i thought about it because in the food
episode i
agreed with gone and said like our beef
is like the best
but then i thought i'm like no wait you
can't cut so much with pork tonkatsu
katsudon that's all pork beef all you
can do with beef is have a steak it's so
[ __ ] yeah like maybe you can make a
burger at the be
it's literally so limited pork you could
every single amazing dish you can think
about that normally has meat
is normally
the fact that you say that you like
streaky bacon over like actual meat
just says the reason why you can't
appreciate me pork just
i rest just tastes like well done
well done beef and as we all as we all
know
nobody nobody [ __ ] likes well done
beef this man did this
[ __ ] texture did he make did this man
just say that
i'm getting a call right now it's from
the circus they want it they want to
know your address bro
like what the what what you're not a
clown you're the entire circus it tastes
nothing like beef what are you on about
because the good the [ __ ] best pile
of beef is like the moisture
and like it's next next you'll be saying
oh duck is just a fatty chicken
that's all it is man it's like it's the
same thing right
how can you say that that's they're not
even remotely similar my god
i've never ever even the the consistency
of the bite is totally different too
every chef who was watching this episode
just had a stroke anyone who was in your
corner probably realizes how much a
[ __ ] clown you are
nah nah i'm i'm sticky in my corner
beef is superior to pork this man
except for bacon bacon is the most
superior part
out here i will [ __ ] with bacon every
day of my life god's out here literally
arguing his [ __ ] like kiddie meal
preferences and food pretending he's at
the gourmet table like get out of here
man come on get the [ __ ] out of here oh
my god